Maybe you’re 35-years-old and you’ve never
had a job.
And one of the things that’s stopping you
is that you’re so damned nervous that you
can’t pick up a phone and use it, because
if anything unexpected happens while you’re
talking, you get scared so badly you have
to hang up.
And so, that would be characteristic of somebody
with a severe anxiety disorder.
So, what do you do with that person?
So, you say: Oh, are they afraid of the phone?
Well, no.
What are they afraid of?
Well, they’re afraid of anomalies in human
interaction, right?
And they’re afraid of something unexpected
happening while they’re trying to impose
a structure.
And the reason they’re afraid of that is
‘cause they never learned that they were
capable of dealing with the emergence of something
new on an ongoing basis, which meant that…
Well, which meant in all likelihood that,
when they were children, they were so sheltered
from any contact with those aspects of being
that transcend knowledge that they never learned
that there was something inside of them that
would reveal itself if they were allowed the
opportunity to encounter the unknown; to encounter
fear, then to master it, then to extract out
something of value.
So, they can’t get a job because they can’t
use the phone.
And it isn’t because they can’t use the
phone, right?
It’s a deeper story than that.
It’s because they’re terrified of this
and they have no idea that they have some
resource they could draw on to combat it.
And you could say: Well, we can teach them
to use the phone, right?
Say: Well, you know, here’s a repertoire
of stock lines that you might use, you know,
like small talk at a party.
And that would increase what they know and
enable them to deal with the unknown.
Or you could say: Look, you know, relax a
little bit.
When the person says something on the phone
that you don’t understand, pause a little
bit.
Think about what they’re saying.
Pay attention to them.
Allow yourself the luxury of formulating a
response.
You’ll do fine.
And even if you do it badly the first half
a dozen times, well, you’ll learn eventually.
And the person derives from that the notion
that, not only can they cope on the phone,
but that possibly, there’s more to them
that originally met the eye
We come into the world equipped with an array
of… possibilities and limitations.
And those possibilities and limitations are
expressed most particularly in our physical
form; the fact that we have a specific kind
of embodied form that allows us to do certain
things, and it also doesn’t allow us to
do certain other things.
Lao Tzu has pointed out that it’s the space
inside a pot that makes the pot worthwhile.
And…
what he means by that is that… those things
that limit you give you as much form and possibility,
as those things that enable you.
What that means, more broadly, is the fact
that you’ve come to a given circumstance
with a set of possibilities and a set of limitations.
It’s that, that allows you to impose form
on what you encounter, so that the whole notion
of form is a tenet in some peculiar way that
we don’t really understand yet on the necessity
of limitation.
And I think the best way to understand that,
or to begin to understand that, is to give
some consideration to the notion of a game.
So, for example, if you’re playing chess,
there’s a virtually unlimited number of
things you can’t do, and only a very narrow
number of things that you can do.
Yet, when you’re playing chess, the arbitrary
limitations that are imposed on each piece
don’t seem to be unfair in any sort of cosmic
sense.
They seem to be part of the structure that
enables you to actually play the game.
Without the imposition of those rules, which
are of course relatively arbitrary in the
structure, there wouldn’t be a game at all.
Now, it’s clear that, for human beings,
games and fantasy for that matter shade up
into reality, so that the game structures
that we engage in and the fantasy structures
that we use to under­gird our stories and
our pretend play, say when we’re children,
shade imperceptibly into real life.
We­We play games because there’s something
about games that make them deeply analogous
to what we do in day­to­day situations.
And that means, the observation that the rules
of a game actually make the game possible
is an observation that’s broadly applicable
to consideration of your own limitation
Some of those limitations and possibilities
take the form of emotions and motivations,
and we know, I think, incontrovertibly regardless
of the claims of social scientists who are
more relativist in their orientation, that
human beings come into the world with a standard
set of biological predispositions – emotions
and motivations.
And furthermore, I think we know that it’s
the fact of those shared emotions and motivations
that allow us to communicate at all.
And then, imagine further that a consequence
of that… lengthy process of interpersonal
negotiation is the emergence of a tremendously
complicated game, and not one that’s arbitrary,
because the game has to have certain rules
in order for it to be played at all.
So, for example, we know that even with rats,
If rats-- They like to engage in rough-and-tumble
play, and if you put two rats together – juvenile
rats – one rat almost always dominates the
other.
It only takes about a 10% gain in weight on
the part of one rat for it to be pretty much
stability dominant.
And it’s always the subordinate rat that
introduces play, or-or-or uh, asks for play.
But it turns out that even among rats, if
the dominant rat pins, or… or-or obtains
victory over the subordinate rat more than
70% of the time, the subordinate rat will
no longer play
So then, you could imagine likewise that if
you’re going to play a game with some other
person, whether it’s a game of fantasy or
the actual chance to engage in some cooperative
real-world activity, unless that person allows
you a certain amount of space for the manifestation
of your own emotional and motivational needs,
you’re not going to play the game with them,
right?
You’re going to look for another game.
And that means that there’s a certain set
of difficult-to-describe constraints for all
of you on games that you’re willing to play
before you’ll look for another game.
Well, and then, you could start to conceive
of revolutionary tendencies in that sense,
right?
Imagine a human society that’s got so unstable
that the vast majority of the citizens within
that society are subjugated to starvation.
So, the society never­­ no longer provides
their basic needs.
And constant tyranny, you could imagine as
well, that there’s going to be an innate
tendency among the members of that society
to start hypothesizing about what alternatives
might be possible, right; to start dreaming
about alternative societies, and then also,
to take action if the situation becomes too
extreme.
And I think this is part of the reason why
you see stable mythological motifs across
different cultures It’s not so much like
Jung said that we have archetypes of what
might constitute social order, deeply embedded
in our unconscious.
I think this­this situation is more externalized
than that in that, what’s biological is
what we bring to the situation – our hopes
and our desires, and the fact that we have
hopes and desires.
Now, I think what happens with stories is
something like this; is that, as human societies
increase in complexity and numbers – so,
they become bigger and bigger – and more
and more people engage in the negotiating
process, exchanging emotional and motivation
information, the pattern that this society
takes, if it’s going to be stable across
long periods of time, starts to become encoded
in the stories.
So imagine, you got your emotions and your
motivations.
You make your case known.
Ten thousand other people do that over a thousand
years, and structure starts to emerge that
satisfies, more or less, all of these emotions
and motivational states, and is also recognizable
as a pattern
So then, you could say, for example, considering
a story like Moses and the imposition of the
Ten Commandments on the ancient Hebrews, prior
to his imposition of those Ten Commandments
– of course, there were actually many more
than ten, Moses - according to the mythological
story – Moses spent years, literally years,
adjudicating conflict between the people that
he was leading.
18 hours a day, they’d come to him with
their various problems, saying: We have a
dispute.
How should it be settled?
And he’d settle it.
Well, imagine doing that for ten years, right;
becoming an expert at evaluating what constitutes
an appropriate solution to an emotional problem
between two people.
Imagine, as well, that as a consequence of
doing that for such a long period of time,
you start to became-- become to abstract out,
lawful regularities in the manner in which
people have to interact in order for peace
to be maintained.
Imagine further that those could be codified
in stories but, even more, codified as law
eventually when consciousness became capable
of grasping, explicitly, the nature of the
interactions
So, my point is a point very much like Nietzsche’s
– because Nietzsche said at the end of the
19th Century that it’s a mistake to presume
that most of our philosophies are rational
in nature.
And I think that’s a mistake that characterizes
Western philosophical thinking, at least since
the Enlightenment.
It’s a mistake to assume that there was
a chaotic social state upon which a rational
order was imposed as a consequence of rational
action.
It’s much more reasonable to presuppose
that the order emerged naturally, over lengthy
periods of time, and then was interpreted
and codified and given structure in a secondary
manner.
And so, what I’m trying to outline for you
in large part is the processes by which that
order comes to be.
So, you say, first, it’s behavioural, emotional,
motivational.
People, and even animals, communicate in a
way that makes their motivational and emotional
needs known to one another.
So, even among wolves and chimpanzees and
any kind of lower-order social animal, you
have the emergence of dominance hierarchies,
fundamentally, which are stable solutions
to the entire set of emotional and motivational
problems that besets the group.
And no one would ever say that the emergence
of a chimpanzee dominance hierarchy is a consequence
of rational deliberation.
So then, imagine that chimpanzees get the
power to watch what they’re doing and to
start to represent it.
And then, imagine furthermore that that representation
takes the form of stories and, then, laws.
And then, you have some idea about h-how human
social order comes to be.
And this is an exciting possibility for me
because it offers-- it offers the potential
solution to one major question, which is:
How is it that people should act?
And because we’re essentially rationalist
in our presuppositions, we believe that there
are rationalist solutions to that.
But the solutions may be something that are
much more akin to biological solutions.
So, first, I want you to consider the following
hypothesis.
OK, so, we’re going to make the presupposition
– a couple of presuppositions that I don’t
think are unreasonable – first, is that
we are essentially animals, that we’ve evolved
in a Darwinian fashion; and second, that the
consequence of that evolution - much of which
was precognitive, right – uh, that we-we
were around as creatures before we were capable
of thinking in words, to say, much of that
evolutionary history has conditioned the manner
in which we think.
So, we think more like biological entities
than we think like computers.
Or, we think more like biological entities
than we think like rational machines.
But of course, we already know that rational
machines cannot think very well, except in
very bounded environments, ‘cause they don’t
have access to an embodied structure or to
emotions and motivations.
So, let’s…
So then, you might say: Well, why is it that,
like, in the Mesopotamian and Egyptian creation
myths, our most fundamental representations
of the world tend to take story form and that,
not only do they take story form, but they
tend to utilize certain kinds of categories.
Now, I’ve showed you this diagram before.
Uhmm, this represents what I think are the
three cardinal categories of experience.
So, there’s the great mother who’s holding
the world in her hand here.
And inside her subordinate – in a sense
– is the great father.
This is a Christian representation obviously.
And then, the tragic son of course, in the
crowd here representing society, is adoring
the figure of the tragic hero here because
they regard his mode of being as necessary
to their own salvation so to speak – their
own proper mode of living.
OK, so then, you think: Well, why these characters?
And I’d offer you this possibility is, first
of all, every human being that’s ever lived
has lived in an environment characterized
by the presence of these three entities, right?
We have mothers.
We have fathers.
And we exist as individuals.
And then, you think: Well, when you’re a
child and you begin to comprehend the world,
the outside world, everything outside of the
family is of course vague and ill-defined,
right, non-existent in a sense.
And all there is for you to observe is the
mother, who for you really is the whole world,
and the father, a-a secondary source of comfort
and trouble perhaps, and the fact of your
own individuality.
And so, you say: Well, that’s true from
the perspective of individual development.
But then, if you go way, way back in history
– maybe 500,000 years when our cognitive
capacities were first starting to develop
– and we were trying to figure out what
the world was really like, what categories
would we have at our disposal to start to
modify and change in order to represent the
outside world.
And then, you might think: You can only talk
about what you don’t know in terms that
you know.
And since, for the child, the mother is the
world.
It isn’t absurd to presume that for the
human being, the world is the mother, first,
as a projection, right, as an a priori, cognitive
schema.
The hypothesis being: The natural world which
of course manifest itself in truth in the
mother – partakes in many ways of the same
properties as the mother.
It’s a working hypothesis, just like you
might presume if you date a new woman, that
she has aspects of your sister – all things
considered – aspects of your mother, given
that they were also female.
You take what you know to represent what you
don’t know.
So, we use our fundamental, social cognitive
categories initially to portray the world.
And the world’s nature is portray and personified,
or metaphorical form.
And so then, the question is: What are the
primary categories?
Well, we have three of them here.
But they’re not the only three because this
is all good, this category system – the
benevolent mother, the benevolent father,
and the hero.
Well, we know the world is not only benevolent,
it’s also malevolent.
Or at least, we can say that because we’re
equipped with certain emotional possibilities
and certain motivational possibilities the
probability that we will encounter despair
and frustration and disappointment, and anxiety
is just as real as the possibility that we
will encounter and hope, and satisfaction.
So, for us, the world is bivalent.
It takes with one and it gives with the other.
And that’s true for the natural world, which
produces us and destroys; as it is for the
social world, which fosters our development
and crushes our individuality; and as well
for the individual, who in many regards is
as admirable a creature as you can hope ever
to propose and, at the same time, someone
who’s capable of unbelievable depths of
depravity.
So… a world that’s not only divided into
three fundamental categories, but each category
divided into a structure that’s essentially
ambivalent in its fundamental element.
And of course, that poses the central existential
problem for human existence, doesn’t it?
I mean, we’re faced with the vagaries of
the natural world and what we don’t understand;
he vagaries of the social world and its often
arbitrary and unreasonable demands on us;
and the fact of our capacity for transcendence,
tied to our own vulnerability.
And you could say perfectly reasonably that,
regardless of where you’re situated in time
and space, those are basically your problems.
And your goal through life – your path through
life – is going to be characterized by the
solutions you either come up with or don’t
come up with to that set of problems.
OK, so, there’s one more categorical element
that complicates this picture.
And I think, in many ways, it’s the most
difficult thing there is to grasp.
So, we’ll take a shot at it first.
And I’ve showed you this representation
before.
This is the dragon of chaos, and you can think
of the dragon of chaos as a symbol of totality.
And furthermore, you can think of it in relationship
to this structure…
as the source of this structure… or even
as the source of all structure.
So, you see in the Sumerian creation myth,
for example, the character of Tiamat, right?
And I told you that the world Tiamat is associated
with the later Hebrew word “Taom”, which
means chaos.
And Taom is the chaos that Yahweh makes order
out of; makes the world out of.
So, the idea lurking behind the Sumerian creation
myth - and then, later, lurking behind the
entire edifice of Judaism-Christianity and
Islam for that matter - is that something
that can be best represented by this figure
is best conceptualized as the ground of everything
that exists.
Now, what in the world can that mean?
Well, it means something like this.
Let’s look at the concrete metaphorical
representation.
And first of all, you have a kind of totality
here, right?
You have a thing that can live by devouring
itself.
So, it has no need of anything outside of
it.
In fact, there is nothing outside of it.
It’s a figure of absolute totality.
And it’s characterized by a strange intermixture
of metaphorical representations of matter
– because a snake is something that crawls
on the ground – and spirit – because a
winged serpent is something that can fly and,
therefore, partakes of the metaphorical realm
of heaven - heaven and earth, right?
Totality--Yin and Yang, from the Daoist perspective.
That’s the entire world.
And it’s also something that’s characterized
by the capacity for transformation because
a snake can shed its skin and be reborn.
So, it’s something that’s constantly renewing
itself, despite its absolutely archaic age.
And it’s also something that presents a
terrible danger and tremendous opportunity,
because a dragon is something that will burn
you if you get anywhere near it, but also
hordes a treasure that’s more valuable than
anything else.
Eliade has pointed out that in traditional,
classic creation myths - the Sumerian myth
being one example, the hero when he encounters
the first the great dragon of chaos he first
either runs away or is paralyzed by fright.
The world in itself is a complex array of
patterns.
And those patterns manifest themselves in
space, and they manifest themselves in time.
And I think the best way to get a grip on
what those patterns might be like is to think
of them in terms of music.
And I think that’s what music represents.
Music is this complex three-dimensional structure,
full of interwoven patterns of different dimensions
and length that expends itself over time.
And if you listen to a piece of music, you
can concentrate on one instrument or another,
or you can concentrate on a phrase, or you
can concentrate on the entire melody or the
voice.
You can parse out different elements from
the complex background.
And that’s especially the case with very
sophisticated orchestral music, right, which
is susceptible to multiple reinterpretations,
and multiple encounters, because of its complexity.
And this is to say only that what you look
at is far more complicated than what you see.
Or to say, alternatively, that there’s more
information in anything you perceive than
you can ever get complete access to.
And that’s partly because, It’s partly
because your perceptual systems delude you.
So, we think you look with your eyes or with
your other senses.
But that’s only true when you’re looking
at what you already know what to look at,
right?
When you’ve already built perceptual machinery
that enables you to detect a particular object.
But when you’re looking at what you don’t
know what to look at, the way you look is
by getting nervous, right?
It’s not-- It’s not precisely a perceptual
function.
It’s something much more deeper and primordial
than that.
And it’s more like: Oh no.
Something that I cannot categorize – either
perceptually or cognitively – something
that I do not know how to respond to has just
occurred.
And the first categorization is this: That’s
it.
There’s-There’s nothing under that.
It’s merely fear plus heightened attention.
And that prepares the ground for constructing
a more detailed representation.
But that first encounter, that’s the encounter
with the dragon of chaos.
So then, you take this figure – the source
of all things, the… the Dao in some ways
– and you say: Well, how does it manifest
itself?
And the answer to that is something like this:
And, we see this both in the-- in-in the Mesopotamian
and the Egyptian myths that I described to
you.
The first division of the great dragon of
chaos, or the primordial egg is always into
two subordinate elements: The great father,
and the great mother.
Why is that?
Well, it’s illustrative of a fundamental--
of the fundamental binary nature of existence,
I guess; partly, you could say: If you’re
a cognizant being – a defined delimited
being – what you perceive always has a binary
structure.
There’s the aspect of you that structured
enough to allow the perceiving.
That’s what you know.
That’s-That’s the manner in which you’re
structured so that you can even… so that-that
you can even formulate a perception – something
a child builds up over time from the primordial
aspect, say, of his visual system or his auditory
system; learns to parse up the world by generating
machinery that allows the complex patterns
that make up the world to be turned into objects.
So, there’s the thing - the structure that
allows the perceiving and then, there’s
the thing that’s being perceived
or the thing behind that.
And this is a very complicated distinction.
You can say: Well, what’s the difference
between the dragon of chaos - say, the representation
of the cosmos as such - and the great mother?
And I would say, it’s something like this…
The unknown that appears in relationship to
a perceiver is different than the unknown
as such.
So, I would say this, for example: There are
going to be things that surprise you that
wouldn’t surprise me, and vice versa.
And the things that would surprise you have
to be construed in relationship to what you--
to what you already know, ‘cause you’re
only going to be surprised by things you don’t
know.
And likewise for me, I’m only going to be
surprised by things I don’t know.
But what we know is going to vary somewhat.
So, the unknown for you is going to be different
than the unknown for me.
And the great mother is a representation of
the unknown for you, for the unknown for me.
Different for everyone in some sense, because
we’re all going to be…
We’re all …all-all going to be stymied
and stalked by different aspects of being;
but the same, as well, in that when you encounter
things you don’t understand, and you encounter
things you don’t understand, in many, many
ways, you’re going to react to those different
things the same way.
And I can give you a narrative illustration
of this.
King Arthur’s knights-- They sit around
the round table.
They’re all equals, that’s why they sit
around the round table, right?
They have a king.
The king determines their destinies, like
Marduk does.
But they’re still all equal.
They determine they’re going to go look
for the Holy Grail.
It’s the symbol of redemption.
So, they’re off to find the highest value,
like, Pinocchio wishing on a star - the highest
value.
And they all enter the forest to begin their
quest, but they each enter it at the place
that appears darkest to each of them, right?
So, that means they all go on different--
They all go in different directions; even
though they’re on the same quest that theoretically,
they’re inhabiting the same space.
So… so, it’s only to say that every person
has their demons, so to speak, and that those
demons differ from person to person, even
though there are things you can say about
the demons that are common across people.
So we know, for example, from clinical work
– from endless clinical work – that if
you want to help someone, you identify: OK,
what do you want to do?
‘cause they need to know that, right?
And that’s this.
What do you want to do?
Where do you want to go?
What kind of structure do you want to impose
on your world?
And then, you identify: OK, well, what things
are stopping you?
What things are stopping you?
So, then, you look back at the Sumerian creation
myth and you think: Well, there’s Absu,
right?
God of the Known, Tiamet’s Consort, right?
Culture, but there’s also Marduk, and Marduk
is the power – the spirit, the entity – a
representation of the Sumerian saviour who
goes out to confront this and to make the
world.
Well, that’s what you teach people in behavioural
therapy.
You teach them not so much that.
You don’t teach them habituation.
You don’t teach them to get used to things
that they’re afraid of.
You teach them that there’s something within
them that can respond to the things that they’re
afraid of - that’s of as great a magnitude
as the fears themselves.